honnêtement quand j'ai su olivier
guimond mais recevant d'entrevue chez
comme fois que la médecine a vraiment
avancé fait le yoga et le log
[Musique]
quand de guérir tous les maux pour les
gens qui ne connaissent pas ouais c'est
une question piège ça fini ton assiette
ya des gens qui meurent de faim en
afrique c'est quoi le rapport mais je
pense que j'ai un humour sur scène qui
est assez accessible j'essaie de parler
d'un jeu du quotidien de ma réalité
j'essaie d'avoir un stand up assez peur
dans la tradition du stand-up y avait
peut-être mon but en première partie
jean marc parent avoir un lotissement de
vianne à quelques gentillesses il en
avait un super truc applaudi j'ai jamais
fait la première partie jean becker
dirais que je raconte de biner mouchetés
raconteurs à la basse
en fait je me dis vie de quelqu'un de
dégueulasse j'allais vous pensez vous
pas mieux si votre compassion distinct
du monde
oui je me raconte beaucoup mais il ya
beaucoup de références littéraires
artistiques culturelles historiques plus
tu vas me chute des billets de cette en
train de planter avec ses sources que
huawei ccb radio canada une chance
commence à verser sa chérie on perd ce
prix la tondeuse
c'est du jack daniel's the one piece
formes tailles oleg et des anecdotes
je parle beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de détails pour raconter ne
sera pas relayée
beaucoup dans l'autodérision aussi parce
que je me dis si j'ai ri de moi un
précieux c'est comme validé le fait que
je peux rire de tout le monde qu'est ce
que ça représente pour toi d'être en
nomination comme révélation de l'année
aux oliviers je vois ça comme une
validation mais par me suis souvent
sentie un poster dans ce milieu là
venant d'un background de musique
classique il ya étudié en arts visuels
si vite ça fait deux ans et demi que je
fais du mot mais je suis arrivé j'étais
pressée fac et je suis vraiment content
et je fais la [ __ ] au fond donc toutes
ses mots sa part de loin de d'avoir fait
assister aux parties ergothérapie
larcher se situe la bonne chose pour
dire que juste d'avoir cette nomination
met fin au québec jusqu'en table parce
que les élevé surtout c'est l'occasion
d'acheter un nouveau tout ça oui et ça
ça me réjouit au plus haut point
pas vraiment l'influencé l'avenir et
bâtons de cannelle être parfois oui
c'est ça comment 10 - response prie
instamment à temps ça nous donne un bon
boss de 48 ans
comment titre l'évolution du mot exact
de l'époque de mon père a aujourd'hui
une victime d'un numéro de tongres en
tong arrière grand parent
c'était comme une blague par trois
minutes c'est sûr que maintenant le tice
est rendu très très très rapide le titre
en écoute le 18 center
vous évitez tout lucide on écoutait
beaucoup avec ma copine
clémence desrochers c'est de la vieille
mosquée plus l'un était plus bas prix
littérature elle fait des histoires de
ce fait des bonnes choses mais ça
vieillit pas pour moi quelqu'un qui
tombe
quelqu'un qui se pète la gueule ça
restera aux tirs du côté bürgler car
aujourd'hui ben c'est sûr que moi je
suis juste content de pouvoir faire un
show abby malaise avant juste d'une
petite école c'est une épopée on parle
alors je dois faire titanic à la flûte à
bec avec mon nez comment tu vois lumeau
au québec les futurs de l'humour au
québec c'est l'humour une question de
point de vue ses commandes sur scène on
donne notre point de vue sur xy sujet
déjà exactement quand les gens plus haut
point de vue plus on va être enrichie en
tant que spectateur fait que c'est ce
que je souhaite je pense que l'humour
est super en santé mais il faut revoir
la façon de présenter un spectacle si ça
existe plus des grosses prod à 500000
parti qu'un décor pendant cinq ans
autant dans un podcast que dans un vidéo
web il ya du monde et qui sont préparés
si la vidéo ils sortent à chaque semaine
avec s'intéressant à bord c'est aussi
que le mot évolué sur toutes les plates
formes à ce moment j'espère juste que le
deuxième degré vont rester très des fois
ça me fait peur on peut plus rien dire
ne rien faire
j'aime jouer sur la ligne dans mon
spectacle exemple mais j'espère que
c'est juste une petite frousse dû à tout
ce qu'on a vécu récemment dans les
dernières années j'espère que ça va
reprendre son essor 4 le titre
j'espère qu'on va comprendre que c'est
un spectacle que ses deux jumeaux il ya
de plus en plus d'humoristes je me
demande quand est-ce que ça va s'arrêter
je serai mal placé pour me plaindre mais
je pense qu'il faut pas non plus
négliger la place des autres formes
d'art dans l'espace médiatique
mettons christine c'est comme la liste
dion d'aujourd'hui pour vriet sens comme
le jama parents d'aujourd'hui
sinon c'est jean michel barrette donges
à renoncer gens l'aiment bruno blanche
est un peu lourde aujourd'hui monsieur
moi je suis l'erreur
[Musique]